we have a um really rapidly growing
discussion forum
on reddit uh it is the david pakman show
subreddit now with nearly
30 000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed
for free you can find it at
davidpakman.com
reddit a few interesting posts i spotted
this morning one
is um a post called we defeated the flu
amazingly and it's a
screenshot of a dr drew tweet now dr
drew has told some whoppers on covett in
the past
but he is right about this and dr drew
tweeted amazingly
only 165 patients have been hospitalized
with the flu
in the united states since october last
season we had four hundred thousand
hospitalizations
the staggering difference may be due to
better hygiene practices
changes in the bacterial gradient field
either way continue
washing your hands well dr drew is sort
of right here i mean
what we know is that coronavirus is more
contagious than the flu it's are not its
reproduction rate
is uh when it's unmitigated is higher
than the flu if you are able to take
measures
that prevent the spread of the flu
by sheer mathematical reality you are
also going to prevent the spread of less
contagious things
because we are taking measures many of
us
we have been to stop the spread of
coronavirus the flu which is less
contagious
has been all but completely destroyed i
read uh
i think it was i'm going from memory
here i believe it's that in the uk
there's only been one pediatric flu
death where normally at this point in
the flu season there would be
way way way more so it's very difficult
to find
anything good out of this pandemic which
has been so destructive
uh maybe the the advance and and kind of
putting into reality
mrna-based vaccines would be something
that would be good and
would be um available in the future for
dealing with other
um diseases that that's a possibility
it's hard to find anything positive
but certainly the absolute destruction i
would say decimation but i think we've
done even better than
90 reduction in the flu season has been
uh absolutely fantastic another post i
spotted this morning on the subreddit
from a user named cop cooper moss who
says
the flag at my local walmart is at half
staff
and i think it was to honor rush
limbaugh writing that quote i'm a truck
driver and deliver to this particular
walmart
walmart store in oregon and notice that
the flag
is at half staff now i can't find any
info online as to any official statement
from the state as to why
other than the whole rush flag debacle
i also know the manager of the store is
really conservative and looks like he
could be
russia's fatter shorter brother i feel
like it shouldn't be up to the store
manager's personal feelings as to when
the flag is lowered or
raised maybe i'm overreacting but for
context about a year ago a driver was
crushed to death when a forklift rolled
over him
and people barely spoke about it the
next day never saw the flag lowered to
respect someone who
literally died working for you but a
homophobic radio personality across the
country deserves that honor
listen i don't know what's going on at
this store um
joe biden ordered flags lowered for five
days
in commemoration and memory of the 500
000 coronavirus deaths
in theory the timing at this walmart
could be over that although if it's a
hardcore
right-wing store manager i don't know
but there's actually a lot of stories of
really random and relatively obscure
places even
blowering their flags in honor of rush
limbaugh
and um yeah i i think that rush limbaugh
was a terrible influence
on this country and on this planet uh
but you are seeing
a lot of people who want to honor his
memory
as if he did something good which is
really destructive and sad to see join
the discussion
on the david pakman show subreddit at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t